hi there today we're talking about big
transfer general visual representation
learning by Alexander Kalashnikov Lucas
buyer Jawa chai and others of Google
brain so this paper is basically an
application / engineering paper for the
community and it is about the task of
transfer learning for visual tasks so
what does that mean in a visual task the
meaning is basically that the input is
an image so it could be a classifier
where you have an image and you have to
say that this is a cat or it could be
let's say a medical image of long and
you have to point out where the defect
in the lung is or or if there is a
defect in the lung or something like
this as we all know this field is pretty
much dominated by CNN's by convolutional
neural networks that take in these
images through many layers of
convolution especially residual networks
are doing particularly well on these
tasks the problem of course is that in
in some tasks you have lots of data and
that's fine because cnn's need lots of
data to train but in some tasks
especially these medical tasks you only
have like very small database look at
this small database you only have very
few labeled samples where the model
could learn from and that just is is not
enough to learn these big models that
would perform well so you will have to
settle for a less performing model now
the solution or one of the solutions is
transfer learning in transfer learning
what you do is you take a large data set
for example the imagenet dataset you
have this big dataset right here and you
train your CNN on that and then you take
that CNN and you do what's called a fine
tuning step on this small dataset so you
take the CNN that you gained from the
large data set as
starting point and then you just train
for a few steps you just kind of adapt
it to this final data set that you
actually want to train it on and that
usually helps and why does that help
because you sort of hope that the the
large data set and the small data set or
at least somewhat overlapping in in
there so the images in the large data
set are somewhat similar to the images
in the small data set it doesn't need to
be super similar but just somewhat and
you hope that the features that the CNN
learns from the large data set are
useful in the small data set because
then if that is the case when you
fine-tune on the small data set that's
this step down here that's called fine
tuning when you fine-tune you can pretty
much reuse those features you only have
to adjust them a little bit you oh and
you just have to learn how to map the
features to the output which now is of
course different than in the original
task but you would won't have to
rediscover the features so that's why
transfer learning can help so the first
phase is called retraining the second
phase is called fine tuning now the
ultimate goal in this is the following
imagine you have like a giant database
of data all right this is giant look at
the size comparison to the others and so
you have this big big database of images
and you train a CNN on that big database
of labelled images now what you're
hoping is that you can do this once and
then this one CNN trained on this giant
data set will become the starting point
for all kinds of small tasks now so
basically you can post this on a
repository online and everyone that has
a visual task will not train from
scratch but they will basically take the
this this one CNN as a starting point it
is very
to what people are doing right now with
Bert or generally these transformer
language models you never want to train
them from scratch you always want to
train from a pre trained state that
someone else has done because usually
the big work is now shifted to the
pre-training so the goal is to find this
one universal starting point for visual
learning and of course no better place
to do this than Google they certainly do
have a giant databases of images they
certainly have lots of computation which
we're going to see is very necessary for
something like this
now they do train three different models
their model is called vit and they train
three different variants vit small
medium and large so the L model is
trained on three hundred million images
the medium model is trained on fourteen
million images so this is the I think
it's called jft data set this here is
called the image net 21k data set which
looks pretty funky it has like objects
in front of weird backgrounds and stuff
like that and the small is simply
trained on the 1.3 million image net
dataset so I mean just look at this
we're in a situation now where the small
model is trained is pre trained on image
net just for reference if you had
imagined this five years ago this you
would not have maybe you would have
guessed it but it's still impressive so
they do release these two models here
the medium and the small one pre-trained
I believe they don't release the large
ones which are maybe that's the price we
have to pay for getting the medium and
the small one the fact that now Google
can use this in their products because
they have probably spent the
considerable amount of
in doing this I'm not sure this is a
philosophical discussion whether in the
interest of science they should really
solve because they do give the the sort
of exact training protocol you just need
the money basically all right but that's
not topic of this video so the the
models here are all pretty much just
residual networks they're all they're
all these ResNet 1:52 I think x4 which
means that basically scale the width of
each layer by a number of four from the
original resonant architecture and
that's pretty much it they just this is
the architecture there's nothing really
new in this paper it's the paper just
details what exactly you have to do
which things exactly matter when you pre
train these things and which ones don't
and for therefore I believe it is a it
is a pretty good paper and I think that
these models here
the M and s models and maybe someone
else trains an L model and releases it
will sort of become the standard like we
have in Burton now so whenever you have
a visual task you're just gonna start
from those in practice so this I think
is mainly relevant for people in
practice all right here you can see the
these models
first of all excellent excellent not
labeling of your x-axis absolutely
beautiful the x-axis I believe is the
number of samples per data class so now
they take their pretend model this bit L
and they fine-tune it on these data sets
so image net is one of the tasks they
fine-tune on or C for 10 C for 100 and
so on and first of all look on the right
side this full thing this is when you
take the entire data set so often they
outperform they get state of the art on
the full data sets
now they do compare against what they
call generalist models so generalist
models are ones that have this
particular training
call where they train on one big giant
database and then fine-tune to all the
other tasks they do not achieve
state-of-the-art on all data sets in
what they call specialist models the
specialist models would be such models
that have this exact task in mind and
therefore they don't care about other
tasks they outperform some of these
specialist models but not all of them so
this is not a this is not the new
state-of-the-art in everything but it is
in this transfer learning regime and I
think even more important if you see on
the left this is in the small label
regime so here you have something like
100 or 25 or ten or even five labels per
class and if you take five labels per
class for C for ten this model so of
course you have to pre train it first on
the big data set but just taking five
labels per class we still get like 94%
accuracy on C for ten and that's pretty
good that is pretty impressive
especially if you compare it to this
baseline model here which is a resonate
pre trained on just the imagenet data
set so that really shows you the power
of pre trained with full data so one
thing they say is that in their big data
set in their three hundred million
images they make sure to remove all the
images that then appear in the
downstream tasks right because otherwise
you it is fairly conceivable that this
database here is just scraped from the
internet and of course these tasks are
often is like C 410 are also scraped
from the internet it's and also image
net and it is entirely conceivable of
course that the test data is already
here and they say we remove images but I
think they just remove exact duplicates
so it could still be that you know
someone has taken image net and then
kind of recoded it into another
color scheme or whatnot or just
compressed it a bit more and and then
they find these images on the web so
it's a little shaky this whole thing
because these datasets might just be
part of one another but you know given
the results I do generally believe the
improvements here but yeah so I guess
what we need is like is people to
actually go out with cameras and shoot
new pictures for a new test set but in
any case let's dive into how to pre
train something like this so they divide
their findings up in two parts how to
pre train and how to fine-tune so how to
transfer to down to downstream tasks and
the methods they find are surprisingly
easy
they'd say there's two components to pre
training the first component is scale so
you have to have a lot of data and a lot
of models and that is a pretty important
recognition so down here they have this
ablation where they scale up the model
and scale up the data so look at this
for example you can see here you have
the different data sets to pre train on
so this is the small data set the medium
data set and the large data set so in
this direction you have data set size
then here you have accuracy not labeled
again I guess we can understand accuracy
that's fine I'm nitpicking up and there
we have the different models now the
larger the dot here is the larger the
model architecture and you can see
within the individual bins the larger
the model the better performance you
usually get
but as you can see like here this
improvement in the large models isn't as
much as when you have much data and you
can also see by the slope of the line
here the larger amounts of data help
more when you have large
models so only scaling up the only
scaling up the mall the data is not as
effective as scaling up the data and
model at the same time and in some cases
like in this small architecture here it
actually hurts to incorporate our data
at least they say that and you can also
see that here and here it just doesn't
help as much anymore if you incorporate
more data so if your model is too small
you can't handle the big date of course
there are weird effects like here the
performance goes down and then up with
the larger data so this might actually
be an effect of the images in these data
sets being somewhat qualitatively
different also with respect to the task
that you are training for but in
generally holds that you need a
combination of data set size and model
size to go up in this I think might be
an indication of where we are in
belkin's double the send curve so if you
look at there's the researcher Michael
Balcon and others people also research
in this area they have this sort of
empirical finding and hypothesis sort of
that if you plot a graph and here is the
number of parameters with relation to
the data set size it's a number of
parameters in relation to disks whose
size of data and here is your validation
loss then what happens as you have very
little parameters you can add more
parameters to your model to get better
validation loss right this is you know
we get a better model and we train that
and we get better and then at some point
you'll start to overfit you know we've
all learned this in our general machine
learning course and there is a point
here the what what is called the
interpolation threshold where you have
this is one so the number of parameters
is equal to the number of data
points which is just interpolating your
training data sorry the data point here
that's trained but then the discovery
sort of is that this comes down again
and it stays down so as you go up in
number of data points sorry number of
parameters with the same data set your
perfectly fitting the training data set
you've passed the number of data points
in your in your model but still your
validation loss comes down and there's
various hypotheses why this could happen
and here we find ourselves maybe in this
sort of situation where if you have a
model right here and you want to scale
it you want to add more data you can't
just keep the model constant because if
you add more data that will shift you to
the left here because you add more data
but you keep the more the number of
parameters is the same so this number
will shift to the left and you actually
go up in your validation loss so maybe
this is actually what's happening right
here the fact that the model is too
small this is just the hypothesis by me
so if you want to up your number of data
points you also have to up your number
of parameters and that will keep it
going and maybe these models here are
more on this side of this interpolation
threshold and the models where it
doesn't happen might be more over here
though that is a big thing to assume
maybe not now that I think about it
since they have even more parameters
here they would be even more here
somewhere
so maybe you add a bunch of data it's
just not as bad there might be some
weird interactions here like this who
knows let's just skip this in any case
the message here is you need more model
and more data at the same time all right
then there is a second message a second
recipe for pre-training
there we work the second method is group
normalization and weight standardization
so they criticize bachelor bachelor as
of course been used a lot
that is where if you have a batch of
data and you put it so these are all
data points you put it through your
layers and it has some intermediate
representation what you want to do is
you want to calculate sort of the mean
and variance of your data in each of the
features and then make it such that it's
nice mean one and standard deviation so
mean 0 and standard deviation of one
that is called batch norm but of course
it is dependent on your batch size so it
is dependent on how many data points you
have because that's how well you can
estimate these mean and variance
parameters and what people do nowadays
is they take these batches and they
group them into different groups and
they distribute those groups onto many
many machines which is called data
parallelism especially with TP use
nowadays you can just distribute
everything to so many TP use I believe
they say they distribute to something
like 500 TP use which and so they have a
batch size of I think 4,000 and they
distribute to 500 TP use so that leaves
them with 8 8 samples per batch so this
is 8 and 8 is just not very good for
batch norm and if you have to if you
want to circumvent that you need to in
each layer globally sync with all of the
other workers your batch norm parameters
and that slows you down
so people have
around this using what they call group
normalization and weight standardization
so these two techniques of weight
standardization is a is a addition to
group normalization they don't require
they the other samples in the batch they
work on a per sample basis and they
normalize the features within groups of
each Channel so the the group
normalization groups together different
features within a sample and then
normalizes across that and the weight
standardization is a bit like
standardizing the features but it
standardizes the weights to be of a
normal distribution and justifies to say
these are standard techniques that you
can build in and they allow you to not
have to synchronize constantly between
your workers at the training time which
makes everything a lot faster and also
not a problem that you just have eight
samples per worker all right so that's
what they do they do large data large
models and group normalization with
weight standardization that's how they
pre train and then how do they fine tune
they say they have a rule to select
hyper parameters they call the bit hyper
ooh and that's just sort of a formula of
how you have one hyper parameter so you
have one I guess it's a hyper hyper
parameter and that hyper hyper parameter
you run through their rule and the rule
will tell you what each of the hyper
parameters should be so it's it's maybe
it's like a lookup table basically it's
it's oh you set this one number and we
give you the rest of the hyper
parameters and that one rule works
pretty well so you only have to find for
fine-tuning you only have to great
search over one hyper parameter it's not
really red anymore is it and then they
basically decide on the
training schedule length resolution and
whether to do mix-up regularization
mix-up is a technique that can help when
you have very little data and it what it
does is it interpolates between data
points and also trains on kind of like
data points of Rome have this class and
have that class just to make more data
available but they also have this packed
into this rule and they of course the
exact settings of this rule are
presented so you can look it up then
they have a stay data pre-processing
resize the image to a square crop out
smaller random square randomly
horizontally flip the image at training
time so that basically described a
standard training protocol here I'm
gonna go mix it to up up to much the
only thing they say surprisingly we do
not use any form any of the following
forms of regularization during
downstream tuning wait 2 K 2 0 8 K to
initial parameters or drop out I think
they only use weight decay during free
training and that's it so let's look at
some of the graphs we've already seen
some here is where they pretty much
outperform the generalist these
generalist models on all of these tasks
including this visual tasks adaptation
benchmark I've made a video about this
this is a benchmark that includes 19
different visual tasks from all over the
place and they have significant
improvement here as you can see they do
not always outperform these specialist
models but as you can see they
outperform for example this on the
flowers dataset and they come pretty
close and here you can also see how much
they improve when pre training on a
larger dataset so so far people have
basically pre trained on this imagenet
data set and now that they pre trained
the larger one of course they gain a lot
of performance and the largest one isn't
even in this in this table so what I
finally want to look at is this visual
task adaptation benchmark this consists
of 19 tasks and they're divided into
natural tasks which are kind of natural
images and then specialized tasks which
are let's say the medical images are not
really natural and then structure tasks
and the structured tasks isn't simply
labeling or locating something
it is tasks where you have to maybe
reason about something so let's say
there is an image and there is a cup
right here and there is a glass right
here and the question is what's to the
left of the glass and you know there's
other bunch of other stuff around here
and you have to say the cup so it sort
of requires a structured understanding
of the image and you can see the main
performance boost here comes in the
natural images which is to be expected
so you only get what you feed in and
this 300 million image dataset I'm
pretty sure that's just a web scrape of
photos or mainly photos so the main
improvement you're gonna get is on
pictures that are similar to that as we
said at the beginning and these natural
tasks have images like that and you can
see that the model here improves
extremely in that category improves
slightly in this specialized thing and
only improves a little bit in the
structured tasks so this as I said is is
to be expected just know if you use this
model know what is in there you have to
know what it does what it does well it
does well on natural images that are
similar to what it was pre trained on
okay so they do have some analysis here
and we've already
when to most of them I find this to be
pretty pretty impressive so they say
when they apply the standard
computational budget of imagenet
pre-training when they scale up to the
larger data set it seems detrimental as
you can see right here the performance
actually goes down when you go to the
larger data set only if you train longer
then you're improves in the access
labeling is just amazing here standard
long longer oh how long you train for
longer thanks but I guess the point is
taken that the you have to invest more
computation along with your bigger model
and bigger data set sorry it's the same
model but the bigger data set and they
also make some other points here that if
you for example if you decrease your
learning rate too early or set your
weight decay parameter different wrongly
that also hurts is on the right here you
see a smaller weight decay initially
looks better so initially or higher but
through the training you end up at a
worse place than a higher setting right
here and I mean they make a big point
out of this but who's to say that
someone else doesn't come with like a
ten times longer training and figures
out that ultimately you start off like
this and then maybe goes up super high
so to me this this that the lessons
learned here is pretty much that there's
always a way to get more performance out
of more compute and probably there is a
way to schedule all of these things
because that's combined with decaying a
learning rate and so on there's probably
a way to schedule these things with the
current reason with this particular
method that would end up somewhere here
we just haven't found it yet because
it's so complex I I would guess that it
they take the case here they make an
interesting point that if you decay the
learning rate too early then you also
end up at a worse place so this this
dashed researcher here the haha the noob
so after eight GPU weeks which come on
what is that eight GPU weeks that's just
eight GPUs for a week that's nothing
nothing it looks like this right it
looks fairly flat and this researcher
now decides to decay the learning rate
and that results in this thing here so
the case the learning rate here here and
here
sorry not not here so the case learning
right here and then it flattens out
again and then decays the learning rate
again ends up at this level yet if you
trained for a longer you can see right
here if you look over eight months you
can see that there is a slight upward
trend still and it hasn't converged yet
and you can in thick if you decrease the
learning rate only later and always wait
for this to fully converge then you will
end up at a better place right here
above seventy again who's to say that if
I just wait here there isn't a slight
upward trend if I wait for eight GPU
years or eight GPU solar-system births
then there might be even a better point
to decay finally decay the learning rate
and then go up I mean again this this
researcher here only takes point five
million steps where you take two million
so that's the first point the second
point is image net or visual
state-of-the-art research is now
officially out of the hands of academia
this this is it if you see things like
if you see a paper dissing on people
that only wait eight GPU weeks to
decrease their learning rate for the
first time and advocating that you
should you know at least wait until
eight GPU
months actually they wait twice as long
it's over that's it yeah bye-bye
maybe maybe you know you want to do some
theory or something yeah
what I find interesting is the mistakes
so since on C 410 they reach like ninety
nine point four percent there's only a
handful of mistakes that they're still
making because it's not that large of a
data set and they do classify it so red
in particular I think means red is the
ground truth label is correct but green
is the machine is correct and the ground
truth label is wrong and you can see
there's a fair number of green things
here and so the model says ship and the
label says cat and the model says bird
and the label says cat clearly this is
this would be one weird cat so it gets
to the point where you you also have to
expect these errors to be in the
training set so it could just be that
the model here doesn't necessarily even
make those mistakes but it's just
somewhat consistent with the training
set in making the mistakes and also here
on image net they have selected ones
where you know the model says notebook
but it's actually laptop and the model
says Mouse but it's actually spacebar
you know the model says help and it's
ski so or here the model the model says
candle but it's a this is a dishwasher
what so you see that the the the types
of mistakes here we get to very quirky
very fine-grained points in these models
last thing I want to show I have never
seen these image net 21k images these
are just funky like look at that
so here's the state-of-the-art
previously I think said Triceratops and
the new model now says it L says
starfish
good job bit L you Wow
probably the correct label would just be
weird and this no okay I don't want to
rag on this too much this is a cool
paper I believe this will be the new
starting point for a lot of
practitioners in when they do visual
tasks I always as always invites you to
check out the paper subscribe to the
channel leave a like leave a comment if
you want I do read them usually and bye
bye